yeah yeah let's get started to open the
summit welcome onto the stage the vice
president for engineering for Chrome
it's a warm welcome to Linus Upson
everyone Oh a lot of people here so not
surprisingly I'm here to talk about the
web and what we're doing about it
in Chrome let's figure out which button
to push that looks good
how many people here recognize this oh
wow there's a lot of old people here so
those of us old folks will remember in
the very early days of the web there is
this thing called the NCSA what's new
page NCSA was where mosaic was developed
the first really popular web browser and
back in those days the way you found
things on the web is you went here and
it had a list of all the sites on the
web and so when you stood up a new
website you sent them an email saying
hey I've got a new web site could you
please link to me on the what's new page
and they'd go do that and have a link to
your website there and you can see here
in was it June 27 1993 we had one two
three four five web sites launched that
day nothing on the 26th it was probably
a Sunday needless to say this this
didn't scale so then the next popular
way for finding things was directories
Yahoo was the most successful of them
and many conferences were held about how
the web should be organized people
talked about ontology x' and they came
up with ways to categorize everything on
the web and we wanted to find something
you'd go to Yahoo one of these other
directories and click on games or
entertainment and eventually you'd find
you know a group of web sites that you
could you could look down and pick which
one you wanted or try a few of them to
see if if that's what you were looking
for and Yahoo at the peak of popularity
had about 3/4 of a million sites in
their directory
I think they peaked at about a million
and a half sites so needless to say this
approach didn't scale for the web either
then came search engines Google being
one of the more successful ones
the the really clever thing that Larry
and Sergey did at the very beginning of
Google was they figured out that just
the text on the web pages told you a lot
about the web but the links between
those pages were also really important
and in fact this chaotic structure of
the web with everyone linking to
everyone else actually told you a lot
about what was important and what wasn't
so that you could deliver really great
search results for people and so far
this is still scaled with the web and I
mean you think about it it's pretty
amazing because there are billions and
billions of web pages out there hundreds
of millions coming and going every day
billions of users and for many of us on
any given day will consume tens if not
hundreds of different sources of
information content services
applications communicate with people all
just by doing a search and clicking on a
link and so we've been thinking a lot on
the chrome team about what has made the
web successful and what are the areas
that it really needs to improve and so
first let's talk about what's made the
web really successful and this first
thing is the the HT of HTML everything
is a link so you can get to anywhere on
the web by typing in a URL clicking on a
link these links can be spoken to people
who have just tried a domain name they
can be written down on napkins they can
be emailed IMed and and so they spread
very freely and it makes it really easy
to try something because all I have to
do is click on a link to do it the other
important part of that is it's it's also
ephemeral in other words there should be
no side effects to clicking on links you
know I don't have to install software I
don't have to update software I can just
run any piece of software untrusted
third party code by clicking on a link
and then when I go away my browser may
end up caching it for a period of time
or something like that but I as a user
don't have to worry about that the next
thing is indexable so web pages show you
all of their text
by default you don't necessarily have to
write it that way but the easiest way to
write a webpage makes it indexable and
so this allows search engines to appear
and even though search engines didn't
really exist at the very beginning of
the web the fact that the web had this
property allowed it to scale to this
massive size with all of these different
pages and yet you can still find things
and you don't have to go manually
organize them into directories and
things like that
the next thing composability was not at
the beginning of the web but not long
after that iframes were invented and it
made it possible to take multiple sites
and mash them up into one web page and
so this allowed you to do things like
embed YouTube videos in a page or put a
map in a page or you know very
importantly for many publications to be
able to put an ad in a page and the
composability also had some very
important properties that the the page
containing the other page couldn't muck
with what's inside it and the thing
inside of it couldn't muck with the the
outer containing page and so this
allowed it to very safely be able to
aggregate content from lots of different
places and make much richer applications
than if you had to go get code and
import it from someplace else onto your
website and that also brings me to the
last point which is safe if you're going
to run arbitrary code by clicking on
links it had better be safe and so one
of our most important jobs as browser
vendors is to make it so that it's safe
to click on links that you shouldn't it
should be impossible for a bad guy to
lure you to a site and then install
malicious software on your computer or
steal your credentials or do anything
like that and so you know this set of
properties is what we think has really
made the web successful because you saw
from those early screenshots the web was
pretty ugly in the early days everything
was great I don't know someday gray will
be popular background page color again
but probably not anytime soon the but
even though the web was kind of slow
kind of ugly the fact that it had these
really nice properties caused it to just
take off and for the better part of 15
years or so most of the innovation that
happened in the technology industry
happened on the web because of all of
these advantages it gave you then in
2007 came
the iPhone and shortly after that
Android and a number of other smartphone
OSS and they completely changed the game
and they reset user expectations in a
number of important ways one of which is
everyone now expects all user interfaces
to have rock-solid 60 frames a second
two animations and transitions this was
not something the web was built to do
but now everyone expects this in all of
you user interfaces other things it did
it gave you the ability to precache a
whole bunch of software and data when
you installed an application so that it
worked well in flaky networking
environments and if any of you remember
the early generation iPhones or Android
phones everything was a very flaky
Network environment I can't remember
what I got 3G and it was so excited I
saw a little 3G on there like wow this
is fast now with an LTE phone every time
you see the 3G Idol all but being able
to cache all of your application code
and resources upfront made it work
really well in these flaky Network
environments other things that did give
you access to a lot more IO capabilities
gave you direct access to the GPU gave
you access to touch sensors it gave you
access to you know raw network access
device motion location GPS a whole bunch
of things that allowed allow developers
to build more interesting applications
and ones that that were more suited to
the mobile environment and and it also
allowed you to bring to bear a whole
bunch of different development tools you
weren't stuck programming in one
language or one environment even Apple I
don't know if you guys remember this but
a few years ago they tried to make it so
that everyone building apps for iPhone
had to write an objective-c they try to
ban other languages and developers
rioted and and this is this is Apple
this is the Apple development community
more easily follows direction and and is
more homogeneous than any other
development community I've seen and even
they rioted the game developers like we
need Lua and they're like I need to
write C++ GL games and so so even Apple
had to back off there so the importance
of being able for developers to use what
languages and tool sets and libraries
they want to use to build their
applications is also really important so
these are all the places where mobile
applications excel and these are all
places where we really need to close
that gap on the web so you can do all of
these things on the web so you retain
all the advantages that web applications
have that native applications lack but
one of our goals on the chrome team is
to really close that gap so the first
thing on the list is rendering
performance so I mentioned before the
expectations around mobile devices now
are everything's is 60 frames a second
and so you know when the web was
originally created you know people
really weren't thinking about how to do
rendering using GPUs how to make it so
that you don't have stutters and frame
rates and all of these kind of things so
there's a bunch of projects we have
underway and chrome to do this some of
which involve new web standards like web
animations so that you can specify
declaratively what animation or
transition you want to have happen and
then chrome or the browser can then
automatically make that happen for you
so that you don't have to write code
don't handle every single frame of the
animation and that allows the system as
a whole the scheduled activity to
maintain that frame rate so that you
don't get glitches other things we're
doing are things like reducing garbage
collection pause time so if you have to
do work to produce a frame you want to
make sure that you can maintain that
constant frame rate it really sucks if
you're trying to produce a frame and a
GC comes and you go away for 60
milliseconds and you drop four frames
and so we're working very hard to both
measure and improve garbage collection
and other VM Layton sees that exists
because in complex VMs like v8 they do
clever things like oh I notice you're
running this function a lot let me
optimize it for you and even the process
of doing that that could cause you to
miss an animation frame and so we're
working very hard to make sure that
never happens and there's a there's a
bunch of work underway to do that and
it's particularly tricky both for
garbage collection as well as
compilation pauses and things like that
because even if you have multi-core and
we work hard to take advantage of all
the different multi-core processors your
location might also be competing for
Kors or even if you're not competing for
Kors very often you may be competing
with the garbage collector or the
compiler for memory bandwidth or cache
pressure things like that so it's a very
challenging problem but we've made a lot
of progress on that so here's some
examples of the improvements we've made
so this was one of our performance
dashboards that tracks Jay s game bench
and you see some changes were made that
dramatically improved performance now
we also look for performance regressions
and we have a lot of performance
dashboards if any of you've crawled
around the chromium site and tried to
look at all of the performance
dashboards I think there are so many of
them know that no human can keep track
of them all and in fact about a year and
a half and ago we had a massive
regression on one of them and nobody
noticed because it there was just too
many for people to keep track of and and
so that spurred the team to think like
how do we solve this problem and so
since the thing we know how to do is
build software we actually built
software to watch all over the
performance dashboards for us there's
they actually found this really cool
anomaly detection framework that was
developed elsewhere in Google and
trained it to look at the performance
dashboards because as you know sometimes
it's hard to tell is it slowly getting
slower or was their temporary regression
was the the bot just having a bad day
and so now we've got the system where
you know I get email alerts when
performance regressions and regresses in
any of these areas and we have a team of
sheriffs that go and look at the results
from all of this and then go figure out
what change caused the regression and go
nag the developer who does that - you
know revert the change or make a fix so
that we get the performance back and so
now even though we continue to add
capabilities to Chrome and the code
keeps getting bigger it's actually in
almost every area that we can measure
faster and uses less memory today than
the day we launched five years ago
because of this continual measurement of
everything basically four places we
regress they're usually in areas that we
failed to measure and then when we find
them we add a new measurement for it and
we work hard to never regress on them
we're not perfect but we're getting
better and better
another area we've improved a lot is
JavaScript performance we've improved on
mobile about 50% in last year or so and
and this is an area that is is is of
course very important to us because most
of the code that you run is all written
in JavaScript and so this goes directly
to how fast your applications can be in
addition we launched a new version of
the octane benchmark so octane is the
the benchmark we use to tune v8 against
because we basically try to put things
in octane that we think are important to
make go fast and then we work really
hard to make it go fast in an octane 2.0
the changes we made there were primarily
around latency for the first time we
have a JavaScript benchmark that
actually measures latency so that if you
have long GC pauses or frequent GC
pauses or things like that you'll score
poorly on the benchmark we also brought
in a bunch of code from inscripted so
basically we have a zero
compiled down to JavaScript within
scripting you know so you're using Azzam
je s style JavaScript and include that
in the benchmark as well now we don't
implement a special compiler or anything
like that but we're just trying to make
generic v8 work well on all kinds of
JavaScript even machine generate it's
JavaScript like the stuff that comes out
of in scripting and and then we also
added some other large programs in there
to really test parse time compilation
time and latency and things like that so
large code bases of JavaScript so that
those things get benchmarked and tested
as well
so another area I talked about working
well on flaky networks and network
performance one of the things we've done
to make the web more usable on mobile
devices as we've introduced this mobile
data compression proxy and it gives you
a 50% savings on the data transmitted
right now we're really focused mostly on
saving data because a lot of people's
usage of their mobile device is limited
by paying for the bits that
get over-the-air and so we're really
focused on on shipping fewer bits to
them but also there's opportunities to
get performance improvements here as
well in addition to you know building
proxies and one of the the biggest
things that the mobile data compression
proxy does is it converts JPEGs to WebP
II images which are about 25 percent
smaller for the same quality level as
JPEG but also by making that image
format available on the web generally
we've a lot of sites that Google have
converted to using WebP II if the
browser supports it and a number of
sites that Google have seen latency
reductions on the order of you know 30
40 % because a large portion of that
page load time is just transferring data
down to the user so if you can transfer
less data you can make the web much
faster and the same is true on video
going from vp8 which is about comparable
to h.264 in terms of quality per bit and
moving to vp9
we're getting a 50% savings in the data
rate and so there's a number of
properties at Google that are moving to
use vp9 inside of WebM to transfer less
data down to users and this of course is
particularly important on mobile devices
so some of you may know how many of you
have met appcache how many of you have
typed app cache into google but not hit
return to see what the suggestions are
so service workers an attempt to repent
for those sins we want web applications
to be able to work really really well
even in flaky network connections or
even when you're completely offline and
so we're putting a lot of effort into
serviceworker
to make that much easier to program and
much more reliable to program in that
kind of model and we're also doing a lot
to add api's to access all of the
different hardware capabilities of both
desktops laptops as well as mobile
devices we've already got parts of the
device motion API in we already have a
location and a bunch of additional
things are underway three other big
things have landed recently we've got
WebGL WebRTC and Web Audio and so this
allows you to do much more interesting
graphics on the web than you could do
before allows you to do very interesting
multimedia both the video and audio and
WebRTC in particular I think is really
going to revolutionize communications
because now you can really anything
about it web is really about
communicating with people and it's a
shame that we've gone all this time
without you actually being able to
communicate with people and and WebRTC
is going to enable this for the first
time it's it's very cool I talked about
some of the api's that have come in
recently the other thing that mobile
applications have gotten to take
advantage of is new UI toolkits and new
UI paradigms so we're working on a
number of things here to make it much
easier to build really beautiful user
interfaces and to make them work well in
touch environments and in different
screen sizes so one of the things that's
obvious about mobile is typing is a lot
harder and so we've recently introduced
something called requestautocomplete
and what this does is it allows the
browser to
member assets of information the most
important which is payment because if
you want to buy something on the web
having to type in credit card numbers
shipping address mailing address all of
those kinds of things it's a real pain
and so this allows you to do that once
either on a mobile device from a desktop
and then Chrome syncs it across all the
different platforms and then when you
want to go check out on a website it can
just call requestautocomplete it shows
you a dialogue with all of your
information filled out and say hey do
you want to send this to the website you
can look at it and say yeah that's great
and click OK
if you need to change something you can
you can select a different shipping
address for example or select a
different credit card but for most cases
this really just brings really really
simple checkout flows to mobile devices
and there's a some other things we have
in the pipeline and along this line as
well another big thing we're doing is
polymer how many people here have heard
of polymer okay it's really exciting on
two levels one this may seem obvious but
in most programming environments you can
write a function in terms of other
functions with web components that
polymers built on top of for the first
time on the web you can actually write
HTML tags in terms of other HTML tags
and bundle the appropriate CSS and
JavaScript within things as well so you
can build real first-class components
and have structured programming on the
web and not just cut and paste
programming and so this is huge and
polymer is a tool kit that was designed
from the beginning to live on top of web
components and it brings both the
structure of the application to make it
much easier to build your app as well as
a user interface layer so you can have
really beautiful 60-hertz animations and
transitions it knows what all the fast
paths are on the browser and tries to
stay on them in fact by definition
there's this constant feedback loop
going between the polymer team and the
blink team so that every time the
polymer team needs to make something
fast the blink team goes and makes that
fast and so by using this tool kit it's
one of the easiest ways to stay on all
of the fast paths inside of chrome and
it's also got polyfills for all of the
other modern browsers as well so you can
write your application once and deploy
it across all the different browsers
so what else is this one I forgot what's
on this slide this is what add to
homescreen right so in the latest
version of Chrome you can now be
browsing around in chrome on Android and
you can take a web page and add it to
the home screen of your browser of
Android so something really simple but
makes it a lot easier for people to go
go back and get their websites again and
of course we're working on making
handling the the source set or what's
the other one called set in source end
yes so that you can handle multiple
image resolutions as well as handling
composition and and art direction and
things like that
which is really important being able to
work across lots of different screens
and and also very importantly we care a
lot about developer productivity so
we've invested a lot in Chrome's dev
tools how many people here have used
them everyone okay so you're familiar
with them so you know if you can't
easily develop debug applications you're
not going to be very productive and so
we really want to make this this better
and better so a lot of things have
shipped recently and when we take a look
here see if I remember all of them we we
have let's see there's projecting
there's remote debugging to mobile and I
think there's also almost the other ones
screencasting the layers panel yes and
so and in addition to that there's a
whole bunch of tools we've developed for
debugging GPU performance because it's
very hard sometimes when you're writing
something you see a little screen
stutter to figure out what happened and
being able to go into the developer
tools and see a timeline and watch
exactly like ah this bit of code was
running right here and that's why I
dropped those frames
we also want to make it possible for
people to use whatever languages or
tools they want and still be able to
deploy on the web so we want to make an
scripting code run really fast and you
take C or C++ code and be able to deploy
that on the web we want people to be
able to write more structured programs
than you can in JavaScript with dart we
want that to be able to run across all
browsers that we just really start 1.0 a
few days ago and with dr j s you can
deploy it everywhere there's even a
number of cases where the dart2js will
actually produce faster code than
idiomatic javascript because i mean a
lot of you here are very good JavaScript
developers but for many JavaScript
developers it's very easy to
accidentally shoot yourself in the foot
and by having a more structured language
compiled down to JavaScript you can
often get much better performance out of
it for most programmers in addition we
have portable Native Client inside of
Chrome so that we can run native code
even faster than in script in resume s
style code and but you can also take
that code and run it in other browsers
with pepper AAS so you can take all the
pepper API s and emulate them on other
browsers and as I said earlier the v8
team is working very hard to take as MJ
s style code and make it run really
really fast in VA lastly you know I
talked a lot about the advantages of the
web of this link ability ephemerality
composability being safe and it being
indexable and these are not things that
you typically get with native mobile
applications but we realized that some
people might want to be able to ship a
native app but use web technologies so
we've invested a lot in contributing to
Cordova which is the open source project
behind PhoneGap so that you can take
what you've built on the web and package
it up and deliver it as a mobile
application you don't get those core
capabilities and advantages you get by
being on the web but at least it allows
you to leverage the same technology
stack for developing across different
platforms including the web so lastly
you know I'd like to thank you all for
coming here there's a lot of exciting
talk
over the next couple of days and so this
is a great opportunity to connect not
only with all the other developers here
in the room but with a lot of the chrome
developers from Google and we look
forward to hearing back from a lot of
you over the course of this conference
we'll be following along on G+ and so
let us have it thanks